[Musique]
la Maison d'Haïti ouvre ses portes en
1973 sur la rue Saint-Denis à Montréal
50 ans plus tard elle célèbre son
histoire avec une journée d'activités
spéciales offerte à la communauté
à la lecture du conte pour enfant
Marjorie Villefranche elle
occupe la direction générale de la
maison depuis plus d'une dizaine
d'années
tout comme Marjorie l'organisme s'est
enraciné à Montréal si je vous parle de
Saint-Michel on est un peu un phare
parce qu'on est on est on est là depuis
longtemps on a on détient un peu
l'histoire de ce quartier aussi depuis
50 ans la nouvelle maison a été
inaugurée en 2016 la communauté s'y
rassemble autant dans les moments de
réjouissance que de détresse quand il y
a eu le tremblement de terre et qu'on a
vu que toute la communauté s'est tournée
vers nous pour des services pour des
soins pour prendre soin d'eux parce que
tout le monde était endeuillé c'est là
qu'on sert un petit compte qu'on avait
un rôle très important dans la
communauté Wally de sa mère Jamila sont
d'origine marocaine mais ils étaient
présents aux célébrations la petite
famille reçoit des services de
l'organisme depuis trois ans on a
confiance en eux et tout le temps ils
font des bonnes activités l'organisme
le travail aussi à la transmission
culturelle un concept important pour
Sabrina fille de parents haïtiens on
apprécie la terre d'accueil et le Québec
mais on veut aussi que nos enfants ils
aient une certaine part de notre culture
à nous on voulait que les gens réalisent
que 50 ans plus tard on est sur les
épaules de nos prédécesseurs pour
poursuivre ce travail qu'il reste à
faire la Maison d'Haïti veut continuer
d'offrir ses services au cœur du
quartier Saint-Michel à Montréal et
aussi continuer de transmettre sa
culture au Québécois ici Alexis Tremblay
Radio-Canada à Montréal